a new way to heal ruptured eardrums
could soon be music to the ears of
doctors and patients a ruptured eardrum
is relatively common as well as being
painful it makes it hard to hear and
exposes the ear to infection that's
because the eardrum acts as a barrier
keeping bacteria and other nasties out
of the middle ear if other main role is
carrying sound waves to the bones that
enable us to hear to do this effectively
the eardrum needs to be thin the
membrane is just a fraction of a
millimeter thick but this makes it easy
to tear a tear is most often caused by
infection which leads to a buildup of
pressure behind the eardrum
but as Tara might also be caused by a
sudden change of pressure outside the
air or a misplaced cotton bud almost all
small tears heal naturally over the
course of several weeks but large tears
may need to be repaired by a doctor at
the moment surgery is the only option
the surgeon takes a small patch of skin
from just above the ear and stitches it
onto the damaged eardrum this works most
of the time but as with all surgery it
can be expensive and time-consuming plus
there are risks including complications
from the anesthetic and nerve damage now
an alternative is within earshot rather
than covering the chair with a patch of
skin scientists are trying to coax the
eardrum into repairing itself the idea
is to build a scaffold which can bridge
the tear then add a growth factor to
encourage the eardrums own cells to
close the wound the scaffold that seems
to work best in a sponge made from
gelatin it can be cut to any size it's a
3d structure so cells can grow inside it
as well as on its surface and it can be
easily absorbed by the body after doing
its job Japanese researchers found that
by cutting the sponge down to the size
of the tear and loading it with a
fibroblast growth factor
a chemical normally produced by the body
during wound healing they could
stimulate the air drum to repair itself
the stunned scaffold is stuck in place
using fibrin glue that forms a clot like
when blood clots to seal a wound there's
no need for a skin graft and the
procedure only requires a local
anaesthetic the sponge has been tested
in patients and seems to work well for
expecting results from a much larger
clinical trial later this year so listen
out for a new kind of treatment for
ruptured eardrums soon